(bright music)
Preoperative testing.
Belinda, take it away. Thank you, ma'am.
All right, thank you.
We're gonna talk about pre-op.
The only disclosure I have is my husband's a surgeon,
so there are a few discussions at home about this.
But in general,
there are not a lot of questions on the boards over surgery.
And when there are,
they're sort of a hodgepodge of things.
So we're gonna cover kind of a hodgepodge,
and try to cover pretty much everything
that you would probably get on surgery except for the stuff
that's gonna come on the surgical abdomen.
So do not spend a huge amount of your time
going back over this.
I mean, this is the kind of stuff you just,
you can look at it, you got it in your brain,
and you're gonna be able to get those questions on the test.
So everybody gets every procedure except
like in office procedures, simple procedures.
But anything that's going to the OR
or the ambulatory surgery center,
these people should have a preoperative evaluation.
And this is just a preoperative assessment.
So it's mostly the evaluation,
it's your history and physical.
So I'm gonna fall back on that several times in this
because it's not an evaluation with a whole workup
of cardiac workup and labs.
It's your H&P and you're going to decide from that
anything that you actually need to get test-wise.
The other thing on this slide is social support.
You're the one that's gonna know what kind of social support
your patient might need after the surgery.
So the only other time I'm gonna talk about that
is a little geriatric assessment.
So these are the things you're going to be looking at
in the history, the patient's age,
and their indications and their functional capacity,
and whether or not they're obese,
kind of the classic stuff in their history.
You wanna know previous anesthesia issues,
you wanna know their meds
and all the other things they're taking
that they're not supposed to be taking.
And then the real evaluation we're gonna hone in here
is their cardiac status and their pulmonary status.
And then we're gonna talk a little bit about
things like risk of bleeding and risk for anemia.
So you saw a 72-year-old patient with diabetes
and hypertension three months ago.
She was well-controlled on her medications.
She's been in for the last four years.
So she's having cataract surgery
and comes to you for a pre-op evaluation.
What will you order?
EKG, CBC, hemoglobin A1C, or nothing.
Yeah, you bet, nothing.
And this is the question they ask all the time.
So please, cataract, they always ask cataract surgery.
Cataract surgery is low-risk
and doesn't need any preoperative evaluation
as far as cardiac risk goes.
So just a tidbit here.
There are 27 million non-cardiac surgeries
in the United States every year.
And there are about 50,000 post-op MIs.
If you wanna do the math there, it's just under 0.2%.
So it's uncommon.
And it's gonna be most common in the people
that we know are at significant risk for that.
So that's what we're looking for,
the people at significant risk.
But do note that half of the mortality
is because of cardiovascular complications.
So when we're looking at the patient's risk,
it's the risk of the surgery plus the risk of the patient.
So those two things are both important
in order to get your total risk status.
So we're looking at our patient again,
overall status, are they healthy?
Do they have mild disease like hypertension?
Or do they have really severe systemic type
of disease like insulin-dependent diabetes
and they have hypertension and hyperlipidemia and COPD.
And you get the picture.
One of the things you have to know is a MET.
It's a metabolic equivalent.
One MET is the energy it takes for you to sit at rest, okay?
The other thing you have to know is four METs.
It takes four METs for you to climb the stairs out there.
And when you get to the top,
you don't have to sit down and rest.
So you can climb the stairs and keep walking.
If you can do that, you have four METs.
And that's good functional status, believe it or not.
So even if it's not,
it doesn't seem like that great a functional status,
that's the number you have to know.
That's four METs, okay?
So when we're looking at our procedures,
a high risk procedure is an immersion procedure
or some type of cardiovascular type of procedure.
So that includes your peripheral vascular procedures.
Low-risk procedures, breast, cataract,
plastic surgery, endoscopic surgeries,
those are all low-risk.
Everything else falls into
that intermediate risk category, all right?
And it's gonna be really important
when we start stratifying here.
So these are your risks for a major adverse cardiac event.
That's what MACE is. Major adverse cardiac event.
And if you look down here,
one of the criteria we use
is the revised cardiac risk index.
So everything that's starred is one of those.
And one of those things is if it's a moderate risk procedure
that already gets you one point.
So if it's a moderate risk procedure
and you have either ischemic heart disease, heart failure,
chronic renal failure, insulin-dependent diabetes
or history of a CVA, any of those things,
now you are at elevated risk, okay?
So those are the people you're going to look at
most carefully.
So who gets an EKG?
If you don't have a high risk procedure,
if it's a low-risk procedure, you don't get an EKG.
Unless of course the patient,
it looks like they might have an MI right now in your office
and you should be getting an EKG already, right?
But you're not doing it for the procedure.
So low-risk procedure, no EKG.
High-risk procedure, EKG, right?
So it's only those people with the low-risk procedures
that you need to make a decision about.
And in those patients, if they have good functional capacity
and they don't have a lot of cardiac risk factors,
they don't need an EKG.
But if they have low functional capacity
or significant cardiac risk factors
that we just talked about,
then those people are going to fall into
the EKG category, okay?
Low-risk procedure, no EKG.
High-risk procedure, EKG.
And then you have to make the different, for medium risk,
it depends on the patient.
Good functional capacity, no.
Poor functional capacity, get an EKG.
You are seeing a 72-year-old for a pre-op eval
for knee replacement surgery.
She has well-controlled hypertension, aortic stenosis,
diagnosed with an echocardiogram three years ago,
she's had no other problems.
Some mild dyspnea on exertion. What should you do?
A pulmonary function test? No further testing?
An echo? Or start on statin therapy?
Very good. An echo.
And they need an echo if they haven't had one
in the last year.
And we'll look through those. So cardiac considerations.
So in most cases,
people with reasonably well-controlled hypertension
can undergo surgery.
The anesthesiologist is gonna manage their hypertension
at the time of the surgery.
But for grade three, you see they're 180 over 110,
that's gonna delay it.
Acute coronary syndrome.
That patient goes to the cardiologist.
That one's straightforward.
And if anybody who's had a recent MI,
you wanna postpone any kind of surgery
for at least four to six weeks.
And you can see here on delaying your surgery,
if you've had a balloon angioplasty, it's two weeks.
30 days if they put in a bare metal stent
and six months if they put in a drug eluting stent.
So try to avoid all other surgeries in those time periods.
For heart failure,
heart failure is a big risk factor for surgery.
And so the patients who are at the greatest risk
have a third heart sound and JVD.
So those are the people
that you wanna look at most carefully.
And anybody who has any new dyspnea or new symptoms
that they're not totally stable,
those people need an echocardiogram.
For valvular disease, anybody who has aortic stenosis,
severe mitral stenosis or aortic or mitral regurge.
So anybody with aortic stenosis,
and then anybody with severe other valvular disease
needs an echo within the last year.
And then obviously if they had an echo six months ago,
but they have new symptoms, then they need a repeat echo.
For arrhythmias, if it's atrial fib and they're stable,
you don't need any eval for those people.
If they have a different arrhythmia,
then they need a cardiology eval.
Right, let's look at radiologic and lab evaluations.
These things we do way too many of. So chest X-rays.
Luckily this has moved a little away,
but all patients used to get a chest X-ray
if they were going to surgery, absolutely not appropriate.
You can see what Choosing Wisely says, don't do it.
So I've given you a number of indications
for chest X-rays in older patients, patients with COPD,
that low functional capacity again.
Patients with heart failure or emergency procedures,
those are the ones who should be getting EKGs.
If your surgery is like really close to the diaphragm,
then you might want to consider it
because that's a patient who's not gonna breathe well
after they come out of surgery.
Patients should be screened for obstructive sleep apnea.
And that's with STOP-BANG, I've given you those there.
They snore, they're tired,
they've been observed to stop breathing.
Elevated blood pressure, BMI, age,
neck circumference is greater than 16 and a male gender.
So if you get five to six of those,
you should be thinking about evaluating,
doing a full evaluation for obstructive sleep apnea.
In most cases,
that's not going to keep them from having their surgery,
but it is important for the anesthesiologist to know
and people who have obstructive sleep apnea
should bring their equipment
if they're going to be staying in the hospital.
Your patient's a 47-year-old female
who's undergoing a rotator cuff repair after a fall skiing.
She takes lisinopril, hydrochlorothiazide,
atorvastatin and and levothyroxine.
She was seen seven months ago for pap smear
and complained of more frequent heavy menses.
Her TSH, lipids and basic metabolic profile
were all within normal limits seven months ago.
Which labs should you order?
TSH, BMP, CBC and lipids? TSH, BMP, CBC, PT/PTT?
BMP and a CBC? Or no labs are necessary?
Yeah, good, you split in the appropriate places here.
So she doesn't need a PT/PTT.
We have no indication for that.
She doesn't need lipids or TSH.
She had a BMP that was normal.
So why would I think about doing it?
Because she's on lisinopril and hydrochlorothiazide.
And so I've gotta be thinking about her electrolytes.
And why would I consider the CBC?
Because she's told you she's having heavy bleeding.
So you have to think about
is she gonna be at risk for anemia?
So Choosing Wisely says,
do not obtain baseline laboratory studies in patients
without significant systemic disease
undergoing low-risk surgery.
Now notice that's low-risk surgery.
But in general, we order far too many tests.
So we should be ordering tests that we have a reason for.
So you can see all of the ones not routinely recommended.
So in patients, just because we're getting them,
just because we're having surgery
doesn't mean we should be getting tests.
Look at the cost. More than $30 billion annually.
We could do a lot of good with that money.
So laboratory testing.
Your analysis now is only indicated
for high-risk urologic or gynecologic procedures.
Basically you're in that neighborhood working.
A CBC, the Anesthesia Society is now recommending this
for everyone undergoing major surgery,
not like an outpatient type of thing, but major surgery.
But be thinking of people at risk for anemia.
So people with chronic kidney disease
or people who are bleeding a lot.
And if the surgery is expected to have a lot of blood loss.
Electrolyte and creatinine testing, again,
think of those for a, like this patient,
who has a reason to have abnormal electrolytes,
and people who are having kidney types of surgeries
where you might be affecting that.
A1C. This is not the place to be screening for diabetes.
So your patients should have a,
if they haven't had an A1C in the last nine months,
and they have diabetes, then definitely they need an A1C,
not because of the surgery.
Now this is gonna be a controversial thing too,
because a lot of surgeons will not do surgery
if the A1C is not within eight or nine.
They have their own criteria for that.
But what you're really wanting to do
is get their diabetes under control
and A1C is a three-month look back.
So what you wanna do is get their sugars tightly controlled
prior to the surgery.
So that may be a one to two week process
that you do prior to the surgery.
Kidney, in patients with post-op acute kidney injury,
there's a really high mortality rate for these people.
So we wanna make sure that we take anybody
who we know has kidney disease into our surgery
in a maximized state.
And it's pretty impressive how low the GFR can be
that you don't have to worry about it.
You can see clear down to below 15,
those patients do pretty well.
But when you get down into that range,
one of the things you can consider
is actually dialyzing the patient prior to surgery
and optimizing them for the surgery.
Coag tests, I'm gonna give you what you can look at
to decide if you need a coag test.
In most cases you don't.
And then the one test that we should err on the side
of getting more are the pregnancy tests.
Because always nice to know the patient's pregnant
before they go into the surgery.
Okay, here's the bleeding assessment.
It's called the HEMSTOP.
And I would recommend that the easiest way
is just have the patient fill this out.
If they're getting a preop eval,
just have them fill it out.
They have to get two things positive
before you even have to think about getting a PT/PTT.
In children,
most common things we see in children are tonsillectomies
and orthopedic procedures.
There are a couple of really interesting things,
like deciding whether or not the parents
should go back to the pre-op area.
That's gonna be very dependent on the parent-child dyad.
In some cases, it's not a good idea.
In some cases, it can really help the patient.
You should think about things like pregnancy testing
in all your teens.
And asking about and counseling about nicotine secession.
Routine laboratory testing in general, in teens,
you don't need it.
There's just, teens are healthy kids,
unless you have a very specific thing going on in the kid,
they don't need laboratory testing.
Today we're looking at the SARS-CoV as well.
So here are some conditions
that require optimization prior to surgery.
You see there's a whole list of them,
but things like airway anomalies, seizure disorders,
malignancies, Jehovah witnesses.
Make sure that you have in place everything you need
if they do require blood.
Okay, you're caring for a five-month-old child
who developed intussusception.
The mother's still exclusively breastfeeding.
How long must the child fast prior to surgery?
Two hours, four hours, six hours or eight hours?
Thanks.
Actually for breast milk, it's four hours.
So here they are. Clear liquids, two.
Breast milk, four. Formula or light meal is six.
And fatty foods or meats or in general,
you went to Wendy's, now it's eight.
So a lot of times,
the surgeons will tell you it has to be eight hours.
But that is definitely not the case,
and particularly for children.
This is a preoperative eval in older patients,
make sure you're looking at cognitive status.
You know what their goals are, their life goals post-op.
Where do they expect they're going to be?
A depression screen is important.
And then this risk analysis is really helpful here.
A score of 30 will give you whether or not they're frail.
And a score of 40 is very frail.
So these are people that are gonna be very high risk
for you.
And again, what's their social and living situation
that you're gonna have to deal with after the surgery?
Here are some things for risk reduction in general.
Pre and post-op exercise therapy, or physical therapy,
particularly in our older patients, very important.
Make sure you're assessing for delayed skin healing.
So again, we're looking for smoking, diabetes,
obesity, malnutrition.
Look for dental infection. So look in the mouth.
Because it's a great nidus,
it's a great place to put your bacteria
that can come out after the surgery.
So make sure you know whether or not
there's anything going on in the mouth.
And always smoking cessation. Always.
Okay, some things that we need to work
with their medications on a regular basis.
These are your diabetic patients. So what should they take?
They're gonna hold all of their oral medications.
You're going to continue their long-acting insulin.
So if they take their long-acting insulin in the morning,
they're gonna take that in the morning of surgery,
all right?
If you're worried, if they're really tightly controlled
and you're worried that it's really gonna be too much,
then cut the dose.
But don't hold their long acting insulin.
Obviously you're gonna hold all short acting insulins.
Another important thing is the GLPs.
So more and more data is coming out on them.
Remember, they slow gastric emptying.
And so some of these people have food in their stomachs
for long periods of time.
And so you're gonna wanna,
since those medications are a week long medications,
you're gonna wanna stop them at least a week
prior to the surgery.
So there's been a lot of stuff in the literature lately
about patients showing up on GLPs with full stomachs
and vomiting during surgery.
So hold those GLPs.
And then this last thing is very important.
They love this question on boards.
After surgery, where do you keep their glucose? 140 to 180.
Okay? 140 to 180.
They've asked that question over and over again.
Statins, we know statins are good,
they have lots of benefits.
And so anybody who has cardiovascular disease,
if they're not already on a statin,
feel free to start them on a statin prior to surgery.
You can always stop it later if you want to.
If they're on a statin, do not stop it.
There is a plethora of evidence that stopping that
puts them at significant risk.
So they need to take their statin on the day of surgery.
Remember it's fasting,
but you can take your medication prior to surgery, okay?
With a tiny amount of water.
Beta blockers. This has been a controversy on and off.
If patients are on beta blockers,
absolutely continue them through the surgery.
Do not start a beta blocker really within the month
prior to surgery.
And definitely not within the week prior to surgery.
There is a significant increase in morbidity
and mortality for patients who were started on beta blockers
just prior to surgery.
So that's the bottom line on beta blockers.
If you think they're gonna need it,
try to get it in them a month before surgery,
otherwise continue them throughout the surgery.
Aspirin, we've been back and forth on aspirin.
And really, the bottom line is this.
Aspirin really doesn't make that much difference.
But it does increase their risk of bleeding.
And so we're gonna take 'em off their aspirin.
And the one place that we're gonna change that
is patients who are on dual antiplatelet therapy
like they're on clopidogrel and aspirin,
you're gonna have to stop their clopidogrel.
So you are going to continue the aspirin on those patients
through the surgery.
Otherwise we stop the aspirin five to seven days before.
Which of the following is true
regarding coagulant management prior to a right colectomy
of a 65-year-old with hypertension, hyperlipidemia,
and stable AFib?
So remember, it's AFib here. So, I'm gonna make this easy.
The first two are,
we're stopping our apixaban two days prior to surgery.
The last two are,
we're stopping our warfarin two days prior to surgery.
So which of those is correct?
And then A and C are,
we're going to bridge with low molecular weight heparin.
B and D, we're not bridging.
So is the apixaban or warfarin correct?
And are we bridging or not bridging?
Ooh yeah. So this one was a tough one.
You're stopping the apixaban two days before
and you're not bridging, okay?
We don't need to bridge for stable AFib.
These are our people that are at high thrombolic risk.
So these are the people we're going to bridge.
If they have a mechanical heart valve,
a DVT or PE within the last three months,
or if they also have a hypercoagulable state,
they have severe or multiple thrombophilias,
active cancer or a CHADS-VASc score greater than seven.
Okay? So those are the people that are gonna get bridged.
And then I gave you the management for that,
for low molecular weight heparin.
These are medications we wanna stop prior to surgery.
ACEs and ARBs should be held on the day of surgery, okay?
There is a significant amount of hypotension
that occurs when patients take their ACEs or ARBs.
So those are one of the blood pressure medicines we hold.
We're gonna stop all of our anticoagulants.
I've given you how long there.
So different ones are different.
We're gonna stop our NSAIDs, our Cox-2 inhibitors,
most of our diabetes medicines,
we've already talked about that.
Our osteoporosis agents, any hormone therapy,
any biologic agents.
So all of those things we're gonna stop.
Any herbal, please get them off of their herbals
prior to their surgery.
These are the ones we're going to give.
They're gonna get parenteral antibiotics.
You don't have to worry about that. They're gonna get it.
Their long-acting insulins.
Their steroids, if they're on large doses,
continue their regular dose.
Their anti-arrythmic agents,
most of their antihypertensives, their statins,
their H2 blockers, asthma inhalers, neuro/psych,
anti-Parkinson, anti-seizure,
benzos if they're on large doses or they'll withdraw.
Your non-biologic DMARDs and HIV medications.
Those are the ones we're going to give.
Steroids.
You usually don't need to worry about steroids
if they're on low-dose or inhaled steroids.
Those are fine, you can stop those.
But if they're on large regular doses, continue those.
If you don't know for sure, you can always do an AM cortisol
and I've given you the doses for adrenal insufficiency.
Opioid management in general, we're trying to avoid opioids.
They are effective however, and for the,
how many of you had surgery?
Mm hmm, yeah,
give me whatever it takes to make my pain go away, okay?
But short periods of time, so about a week,
you'll notice that a week to the high end here is two weeks.
And so don't give opioids longer than that.
And please see that other one.
Serious respiratory depression may occur
when opioids are administered to patients
who are getting gabapentin or pregabalin.
So be aware of that.
These are your post-op pulmonary complications.
The risks of that, again, those are kind of the people
you're gonna get chest X-rays on.
Those are the common complications.
Remember that from medical school
like atelectasis and pneumonia
and prevention is that inspiratory spirometer
and early ambulation.
This is a post-op delirium risk factor list,
which can be very helpful for you with your older patients.
So look through that.
For thromboembolism prophylaxis,
in most cases it's early ambulation.
If they're at greater risk,
then you can use those intermittent pressure devices
or compression stockings, and sometimes both of those.
Dental prophylaxis,
they're starting to actually ask this now.
It's indicated for prosthetic heart valves,
previous infective endocarditis, congenital heart disease.
Okay? That's it.
Notice I didn't say knee replacement.
I didn't say ortho, so not indicated for that.
So previous orthopedic procedures
or joint replacements, not indicated.
And this is the last question.
You remove a five millimeter basal cell cancer
from the arm of a 60-year-old.
Close the wound with four sutures.
What do you put on the wound?
Okay, excellent. It's petrolatum.
And you don't need antibiotics on it.
Okay, so there are some odds and ends
and you can look over those.
But those have been questions in the past. And that's it.
Really, you are ready for the surgery part of the test.
So thank you very much.
(bright music)